after starting with a slinky alley
cannon and Jesse are still on track to
confirm the myth that a car can be
briefly induced to hover you levitate
but it's one heck of a stretch from a 12
pound bowling ball to a 3,000 pound
automobile
today is a crazy day we're literally
dropping a car from a crane I'm excited
I can't wait
scaling way up from those elastomers
strips
they've sourced a giant bungee custom
made from multiple strips of rubber
given that this rubber has a capacity to
stretch 400% it just keeps going they've
decided that suspending the car from the
crane ten feet off the ground requires a
12 foot long bungee
with preparations complete guys ready
yes here we go we're driving the first
step is to carefully fit the car perfect
right there into a hefty sling for
hoisting well give it a slight lift so
we can figure out the center of gravity
but then it's gonna be time to attach
the bungee and that's when it's gonna
get epic nice we bring you the sine wave
this is a seriously big scale experiment
so Adams unearthed some hardcore
hardware this right here is the famous
Mythbusters 10,000 pound quick-release
we've been using this thing for almost
15 years it is activated by this
pneumatic cylinder which gets its air
from this pneumatic tank setting off
this quick-release and letting this car
supposedly hover in midair for a few
hundred milliseconds but first they have
to get it off the ground
the massive bungee stretches and
stretches for a while there's serious
doubt it will actually lift the car
we have liftoff oh my goodness that's
crazy
I thought we were in trouble there for a
second but we're fine that's a lot of
stretch on that thing finally they're
ready to test if a car without added
weight can defy gravity cannon-armed it
the rig is armed all right Jesse
gravity-defying car with bungee in three
two one that was pretty cool oh I don't
think that levitated you don't think at
all we'll have to look at the high-speed
I guess but I didn't really see anything
with first time couldn't see a darn
thing either the cars are right off but
what about the myth well the high-speed
has the answer they've done it
that's 476 frames which is 95 points in
milliseconds that's not very long but
that's still pretty cool and there's
every chance there's something cooler to
come because this is a two-part grand
finale
you know what's better than dropping a
car dropping a car twice which is what
we're about to do in all of the scale
testing the Mythbusters kept determining
that the hover time could be increased
by putting an equivalent weight to the
payload at the top of the stretchy
medium they were experimenting with and
that is exactly what I'm sitting on a
vessel of water equivalent and weight to
the car behind me we're gonna put this
at the top of the bungee with the car at
the bottom and see if we can't increase
the gravity defying properties of that
car stop all right this is the final
hood gun you can start to go up Nick
again the delicate lift proceeds at a
snail's pace to hopefully avoid snapping
the bungee and the team is stretched and
unlikely physics phenomenon to the limit
and whether it hovers or not they're all
keyed up for a smashing finale for the
glory it's even better than last time
car bungee test wait final test in three
two
did it work no that's awkward what did I
do that six tonnes dangling midair and
the very real chance it could all come
crashing down at any second what we
found is we think that the safety the
safety pin didn't fully come out or the
electronics at the top haven't been
working either way we'll figure
something out to get this down I hope
this still has no safety on it the car
and tank are lowered
inch by precarious inch until Adam can
safely assess and repair step we had a
failure of the rig in midair which was
pretty scary because this winch several
thousand pounds and so does that we
isolated the problem to an air leak
which no longer exists and we should be
able to drop a car soon with the fault
found and rectified all right Nick up
just a little bit
the double load is once again lifted
into position that looks lovely
alright guys are you ready yes
alright cannon-armed commence primary
ignition Emily
call it in Bunji test with two weights
final test in three two just completely
chopped the car in half oh yeah that was
so much fun
the water just flowing out but the naked
I can tell if the car and tank hover
so it's off to the high-speed that car
that's definitely levitating this car is
definitely defying gravity right now
question is did it hover any longer than
the car by itself the second drop was
732 frames so that's one hundred forty
six point four millisecond that's a lot
better than the last one
it sure is the car alone resisted the
pull of gravity for 95 milliseconds and
the car with its equivalent weight in
water a hundred and forty six
milliseconds it's an all-round success
they've proved again that adding and
distributing weight actually amounts to
more over time I'm not really good with
math but uh we just crushed a car we
totally just crushed a car